you
most really big things start with a
pretty simple story
Ramsey's are workers i worked feels like
my whole life i've never complained
about I'm not whining about it I mean
but I remember when I was 12 years old I
came in I asked my dad I was gonna ride
my bicycle I used to ride my bike down
to the local quick sack it was about a
about a mile down the road from us and
came and asked my dad for some money to
get an Icee at the quick-set and he says
you know I hold you and I said [ __ ] your
son I'm 12 you know these things and he
said what that means you need a job you
don't need money because that's where
money comes from we said what could you
do to earn some money and I said well
some of my buddies are cutting grass I
guess I could cut grass and even good
getting a car so true story took me down
on Nolensville Road in the Woodbine area
there in old Nashville to a print shop
and the old-fashioned print shop that
used to do letterheads and business
cards they printed up 500 business cards
that said Dave's lawns when we got home
he said you gonna knock on the closest
50 doors in the neighborhood and you ask
them if you can have the opportunity to
provide their lawn care needs and I did
it and it worked I got 27 yards to cut
it 12 years old
I learned customer service and I learned
keeping your word and I remember having
all kinds of little businesses all the
way through school might let little
leather bracelets that you would stamp
people's names on and paint them in and
sell them on the out there hulking them
by the lockers and I've just always
worked and so when I graduate from high
school at 18 years old i sat for and
passed my real-estate exam
I'm a dad Odin a real estate company and
so I started selling real estate while I
was in school then I took off the other
end of the state the University of
Tennessee at Knoxville and took my
license over there work for a guy over
there and I work 40 to 60 hours a week
while I was going through school and I
graduated from school basically broke
but not deeply in debt because I've been
working my wife Sharon Ramsey she is a
central element a proverbs 31 woman who
can find a virtuous wife for her worth
is far above rubies the heart of her
husband safely trusts her and he will
have no lack of gain Sharon and I got
married and started literally with
nothing you know I remember when we
first got married we were so broke it
was unbelievable
we bought our first two pieces of
furniture an old couch and this oh
pedestal table if it could talk wow the
stories it would tell but eventually
after doing some selling of real estate
for a builder I started buying and
selling real estate in my very early 20s
just a couple of years after getting
married and it worked a little bit of
family connection with some bankers and
stuff that would new me and trusted me I
don't know why I was 22 years old 23
years old but they started loaning me
money and I got rich I ended up with
about 4 million dollars for the real
estate about 3 million dollars for the
debt so that's differences a million
dollar net worth and at 25 26 years old
I was making $250,000 a year cash
taxable income it was amazing I mean the
neighborhood I grew up in 20,000 bucks a
month that's rich I was rich I mean we
we did all the stuff we had dreamed of
doing and I'd always wanted a Jaguar
that was my car I'd dreamed of having a
Jaguar I set that goal back when I was
in college and so I got my Jaguar man
and everything seemed to be going right
it was incredible
and our first baby was born Denise and
then and we're cooking along and you
know about that time I start going to
church and I met God in the process and
weird thing happened it was right about
that time that everything start falling
apart
September 22nd 1988
I remember that the banks got sold main
bank we were dealing with we had
1,200,000 with them and 90-day notes
because we were buying property and
flipping it and that bank got sold to
another bank and the guys in another
state in another city looked down and
said you know there's a kid 26 years old
here owes us 1 million two hundred
thousand dollars this is ridiculous
let's limit this relationship which is
banker talk for college notes and screw
up his life so they called her notes
gave me 90 days to come up with a
million bucks there's no way started a
crash I couldn't stop and word got out
on the street that I was in trouble and
I was in trouble and our second largest
lender we had 800,000 out with them they
called our notes about 60 days later
after the first one so we had less than
six months to come up with two million
dollars and it's all in real estate you
can't sell real estate fast enough to
pay that bill we'd never lost money on a
deal we've never been late a minute on a
note ever that didn't matter though they
just decided that they were going to
limit their relationship they were in
freakout mode in the in the economy that
we were in right then and those two hits
started a crash that we fought for two
and a half years no one wins without
paying a price
the scripture says no discipline seems
Pleasant at the time but painful we sold
everything as fast as we could and it
doesn't matter what you do when you pile
up stupid as I as I piled it it's gonna
fall down and you can't catch it all so
no matter how hard I fought no matter
how smart I was no matter how much I
kept my word no matter how much I was
gonna do the right thing and pay
everybody it didn't matter I couldn't
control the outside variables and I
remember being so scared Sharon and I
there was a lot
of separation between us she's pretty
freaked out and scared pretty ticked at
her husband I have any answers I was the
guy that had had all the answers the
weird thing was we paid the four million
dollars down all the way to three
hundred seventy eight thousand was
unbelievable but some of the little ones
we had been sued hundreds of times it
felt like I don't know exactly how many
it was it was close to 100 easy and one
of those little lawsuits decided on that
they were going to execute on the
judgment and they arranged with the
Sheriff's Department to come take a
furniture out of our house on Friday
morning so September 22nd of 1988 we met
with a bankruptcy attorney that night we
signed bankruptcy papers I'll never
forget that he filed him on Friday
morning so we filed bankruptcy on the
23rd to keep the sheriff out of our
house and keep him from taking the baby
bed well we I was out of gas I didn't
have enough emotional energy to fight
anymore I mean we were just beat up and
beat down right after that we started
finding out God's Word had something to
say about money and this really wasn't
the end of the story
so I met God on the way up but I got to
know him on the way down without a doubt
I started studying Biblical Finance and
comparing what the Bible and common
sense has to say about money comparing
that with what I had learned in academia
because I've got all these letters and
licenses after my name that says I'm
supposed to know something about money
but their asset broke I started applying
new ideas like a budget and like an
emergency fund and like getting out of
debt staying out of debt and we had a
guy at church come up to me MacGregor
not long after and said hey can we have
a cup of coffee with you and your wife
we're going through financial garbage
and
you know it's about to tear our marriage
apart it looks like y'all made it how
did you make it we're like going we
barely did so we'll talk to you that you
know so we had a cup of coffee with him
I guess it was my first financial
counselling session probably I got a
budget out I remember getting the yellow
pad out saying dude you got to do a
budget tell me weren't you
and I'm sitting there trying to look at
his numbers I thought man I can really
work I can really show people how to win
with this and I could see it instantly
in other people's situations I guess
because we had been there at a friend of
mine says having a testimony is a great
idea but getting one is a pain the
scripture says no discipline seems
Pleasant at the time later on however it
produces a harvest of righteousness and
peace for those who have been trained by
it we've spent a lot of our time and
effort in not only being educational but
being aspirational to lift and to make
people believe because when you believe
you can do a lot of things that really
don't even make sense
it's crazy what people can pull off when
they believe they can and it's crazy
what they can't pull off when they don't
believe they can I've watched a lot of
people file bankruptcy that were not
bankrupt they're just scared the light
at the end the tunnel was an oncoming
train for them they didn't believe that
there was anything out there that was
real that they could turn the corner
they they were hopeless and that broken
spirit there's almost nothing that can
overcome it but the fuel is the hope
when we did the class we cut up the
credit cards I took them and ground them
all up I looked at this thing every day
I shook my fist at it you're going down
you're going I lost my job
hi um and I'm so behind on everything
pretty freaking scary it oh my god you
have no idea yeah to have been there I
think you're going to have 100% of it
paid in less than a year that's what I
predict not having a future plan for our
kids really was a big big motivator to
us to say hey we can do it look at all
these people that are doing it thing
that kept us going is the support group
that the radio station really is and
what you're doing I'm glad we were able
to help you and if you need some more
help you call me anytime that's what
we're here for
it doesn't make sense in our story that
we were able to pay down from three
million dollars in debt all the way to
three hundred seventy eight thousand
dollars in debt in two and a half years
and I was 26 years old that doesn't even
make sense
it's not logical and we still didn't
make it but but the fact that we got
that far into it was because we really
believed we were going to make it and
when it ended was when we didn't believe
anymore
so that sense of hopelessness I got a
barometer I've got a meter I can smell
that on people I can feel it on the a
call that's coming in when I'm sitting
in a book line I can look up see in
somebody's eyes and I just stop a second
and talk to him and pray with him and
give him a couple of little pointers or
hook him up with one of our counselors
because they came in there they weren't
looking for a book they were looking to
believe again our mission statement lamp
oh group says lipo group provides
biblically based common sense education
and empowerment which provides hope to
everyone in all walks of life that has
been our guide it's not a brochure or
filler it is who we are it is our
mission that's what that says we
realized really quickly that people
whose numbers would work they couldn't
turn it around because they didn't
believe they could turn it around
Zig Ziglar is to say if you think you
can or you think you can't you're right
that's hope I was a kid we would build
campfires on by the lake we'd go camping
with our families everything they'd make
the kids get up all the driftwood and
then we'd be ready to light the fire and
it was always wet new couldn't get it
light everything else and so one of the
old redneck guys would always have a can
of gasoline and you know he'd throw some
gasoline on there and we'd like to guess
little minced on fire right but that's
what hope is it's like the gasoline on
there
it sets you on fire and allows you to do
things that you never dreamed you could
do
we open a little counseling office Russ
Carroll joined me we taught our very
first class in March of 1994 called life
after death with a bad suit an overhead
projector I thought well teach this
financial stuff I've learned the hard
way
and the little class had 37 people in it
and when I finished teaching in a few
years later there were 350 in it so
obviously we touched a nerve we'd found
a need and pastor came by one of my
associate pastors and said you need to
write your story in a book because God
gave you the story and it's different
than other people's stories gives people
hope so I came home that night and I
wrote what was I thought the opening
chapter to financial peace ended up
being the forward and so we're just
living hand-to-mouth doing real estate
and yet I got this bug about this
financial stuff and so at night I'm over
at the church doing a counseling session
or at night I'm sitting at my computer
typing and so that little blue financial
piece book was born we took it to a
printer and printed up the first
thousand oddly enough I'd been on a
radio show as a guest and this guy was
doing this show we used to laughingly
call it the bad financial hour like a
Saturday Night Live skit nobody listened
this station so we went on there he and
I talked about that for a little while
he had gone broke in real estate too and
so we just started having this
conversation about going broke and I
said yeah I'm actually helping people
over my church sometimes that are in
foreclosure and stuff and the phone
started ringing and we took some calls
and he goes that was pretty cool you
ought to come back let's do that again
and then the guy quit and a buddy of
mine call me I mean the mutual funds
business and he says hey we need to go
down there do that radio show that got
quit and he goes listen it'll be fun
I'll do it a couple days a week you do
it a couple days a week
and you know you can look at it as a
ministry and and he knew about the book
I had just written and he said who knows
you might himself some that stupid
little book you wrote you got to get
this cleaned up for the sake of your
child right then worth it though well
good for you when you keep doing smart
stuff for five days you have a good
result you do smart stuff for five years
you really start to see a thing take on
a life of its own you're making good
progress kiddo yeah we're trying there
was immediately
gravitational pull because uh we were
offering instruction which gave hope
human answers that stuff nobody talked
about out loud it was like the secret
that nobody discusses the dirty little
secret that everybody looks good but
it's broke and we open that can of worms
and it just blossomed weird thing is is
that we went on the air June 25th of
1992 that same week the phone rang
printer was on the line and he said your
books are ready and so I drove out and
got my books and we filled up the car
with them and put them in the trunk and
strapped the trunk down with a big piece
of rope and the cars driving like this
and I'm driving home and I remembered in
my prayer time that God had told me he
was going to give me a way to sell the
book and it's gonna be so unusual that I
wouldn't be able to take credit for my
marketing genius and I'm driving home
and I suddenly made the connection that
little radio show was gonna be how God
was gonna sell this book
and I just became overwhelmed I to pull
over saw the road not a southern cried
for me it was amazing and to this day I
don't take that for granted all of this
stuff started from
primitive humble beginnings that would
give you no indication any of it was
going to succeed but I want to challenge
you live like no one else so that later
you get the opportunity to live and to
give like no one else I look back and go
this radio show one of the largest talk
radio shows in all of North America
right now the book financial peace and
how it took off as a result and it's now
had literally millions of families go
through it
over the last several decades you know
there's no way I could take credit for
it I've worked hard but when I look at
the the way that stuff lined up that was
just God's gift
it was just what's called a blessing
we're just regular people from Antioch
Tennessee we're not anything super
special we just did the stuff I've been
teaching you and tried to figure out
what God's telling us to do and doing it
on a regular basis we're just Joe every
guy I started with nothing did stupid
stuff to fail your part and the belief
that I can still go out there and win
everyone's story has an arc to it
everyone's story has a problem and the
opportunity to overcome the problem and
then a resolution sometimes it's more or
less zeroes sometimes you know it's
someone from a little different culture
where they started from a different
mindset a different family upbringing
but they still have that same story arc
and it's still a story arc of folk and
so we unashamedly use our story to help
people to make them believe that they
can win sharing a story or handing off a
story or connecting to a story in our
case you would do it because it's
someone that needs hope I can hand this
Total Money Makeover book I can hand
this financial peace book I can hand
this class or tickets to a live event or
are just a link to the radio show I can
connect this hurting person with this
story of resolution we're all
intertwined that way
because it turns out our story as always
your story
they connect and that connects to
another one and that connects to another
one and that's how this whole thing is
happened there's nothing about the story
we would change we would have changed it
while we were in it but looking back on
it there's nothing about the story we
would change